Dian Fossey was definitely a pioneer I
do not think that word has been overused
before that nobody had done a long-term
study of gorillas
nobody had studied them month after
month and year after year she wanted to
be the scientist who began the first
long-term field study of gorilla
behavior in their society and to take
that as far as it would go
I've been following one gorilla group
round all month and I'm now able to get
within 30 to 60 feet of them to be
perfectly frank I think they're quite
confused as to my species
[Music]
in order to study them and learn about
the behavior Diane had to get them used
to her and that process is called
habituation winning the trust
[Music]
the habituation process is not nice
because you're upsetting this family of
gorillas day after day after day
[Music]
Diane's methods played on the gorillas
curiosity so she would behave in ways
that would elicit the curious rather
than an anger response when she was
climbing a tree to get a better look she
would deliberately ham it up and she
found that that got their attention I've
gotten them accustomed to me by aping
them and they are fascinated by my
facial grimaces and other actions that I
wouldn't be caught dead doing in front
of anyone I feel like a complete fool
but this technique seems to be working
[Music]
you